we begin this morning with the latest
staff shake-up in the Trump
administration Health and Human Service
Secretary Tom Price resigned after
criticism about his use of hundreds of
thousands of dollars of taxpayer money
on private charter flights the president
said he was disappointed by price and
now those costly trips are heightening
scrutiny of other administration
officials Errol Barnett is traveling
with the president who is spending the
weekend at his New Jersey golf course
Errol good morning good morning in a
letter released last night president
Trump's budget director sent a warning
to all agency heads be cautious of how
you spend hard-earned taxpayer dollars
and seek chief of staff John Kelly's
approval for any government chartered
aircraft
the last thing president Trump wants to
be associated with is wasteful spending
so I was disappointed because I didn't
like it cosmetically or otherwise
President Trump had harsh words for Tom
Price Friday afternoon commentary that
was followed by this letter in which the
Health and Human Services Secretary
stood down in order for you to move
forward without further disruption he
wrote I am officially tendering my
resignation her the concerns I've heard
the criticisms price a former Georgia
congressman had tried in vain to end the
growing controversy around his chartered
travel offering to reimburse the
government nearly 52,000 dollars a
fraction of more than four hundred
thousand dollars he spent on at least a
dozen private flights since May an
unwelcome fact as the president tries to
promote a new tax plan that's
unacceptable to me price was already on
shaky grounds with President Trump he
was the administration official
responsible for overseeing the gops
repeal and replace attempts which failed
repeatedly by the way you're gonna get
the votes he better get him otherwise
I'll say Tom you're fired and price
isn't the only cabinet member under
scrutiny for wasteful travel according
to information obtained by CBS News EPA
Administrator Scott Pruett has spent
nearly $60,000 on non commercial travel
since February when cheaper alternatives
were available also under fire Treasury
secretary Steve Manu
and interior secretary Ryan's Enki who
tried to defend himself every time I
travel I submit the travel plan to the
ethics department that at value is it
line by line
now Tom price is the ninth White House
official to either step down or be fired
but he is the first cabinet member to do
so deputy assistant secretary for health
Don Wright becomes acting secretary for
HHS until a replacement is chosen
Anthony Errol Barnett traveling with the
president thanks Errol